today I wanted to talk a little bit
about timing timing and chess and what
does that mean
timing have you ever gotten into a
position where you want to move right
like you're just hoping it yeah you're
hoping it's your move
right that's timing yes what's what did
you want to say yeah
exactly it wasn't your turn and that I
know exactly well timing a chest that's
so very important when you start the
game you really love it to be your move
because you want to mobilize your pieces
really really quickly and during the
middle game you want it to be your move
so you can capture your opponent's rook
or if you're attacking his Queen and he
doesn't move it away you want to be able
to capture as Queen as you get into the
endgame timing becomes more and more
important
who has the move and so I'm going to
give you a little bit including one of
my favorite favorite positions that
involves timing now basically you guys
are white here you guys are you guys
have a pawn up and if you can promote
the pawn to make a queen you're gonna
checkmate me and win the game but the
point is is how are you going to do it
right now my king is in the way it's
stopping your pawn and I'm trying to as
black control the square e8 so that you
can't promote your pond if you can't
promote your pawn the game's going to be
a draw but here a little timing comes
into play so to the class I'd like to
ask what would you do to start and
remember you've got to win yes what
would you do young man
okay you would put exactly it's on e -
let's assume that you play E to e for
well I'm going to wait I'm going to play
King to e6 now what would you like to do
would you like to advance your pawn
further would you what would you like to
do
excellent okay
I'm going to drop back with my kick King
to e7 and now what would you do
excellent choice
there's very nicely done I'm going to go
king f7 yes would you okay that's fine
let's see what would happen after check
is good king e7 and now what would you
do young man
excellent choice and I'm going to go
back with my king came to e8 what would
you do young man
excellent King to b6 King to d8 and now
what would you do
well would you do young lady what would
you do
okay if you move just a second just a
second if you move the pawn to e7 I go
King DEA now check this out
this is timing this is the problem of
timing now in this position you would
love it to be blacks turn right because
if it was black to move I'd have to move
away and then you could go King to d7 in
your next move is e8 and you win but
unfortunately in this position after the
e7 check King here if you go King e6 I'm
stalemated I made the draw I can't move
I can't make a I can't make a legal move
and I can't be obliged to make an
illegal move I can't I can't take the
pawn I can't move my king so it's a draw
stalemate now let's go back just a
second to this position and somebody
suggested king c6 I would go King e7 you
would probably depend upon and I go King
e8 and you can't push me away from the
e8 Square yes and with everything you do
already everything you do at this point
it's too late I've already made a draw
you can't push me away from d8 if it was
my turn you would win brilliantly I
would move my king to e8 you play a
seven and you win but unfortunately it's
your move so we're going to go back to
the start because after the movie okay
well no we still have it we still have
the same problem as we did before but
it's going to be White's turn to move
first and we've seen that advancing the
pond here early quickly which looks like
the right move actually is wrong in
timing and chess
sometimes what that means is you want
the opponent to move you want to lose
the move okay
so we know from what we've just seen
that the move e to e for doesn't win the
game young man what would you do ah move
the pawn to e3 then let's say I go King
to e6 now what would you do
young man okay pawn to e4 and guess what
we're right back into the same situation
as before young man I'm gonna give you a
heads up you've already blown it you've
already blown it it's a draw if you
attack me with check there's nothing you
can do there's nothing you can do to get
me out of the ee8 square I always drop
back here I have three legal moves to
lose on the spot if I move my King here
this loses on the spot to what we've
just seen before the King has to move
out of the way the King moves up again
black to move he has three legal moves
King d8 King e8 King f8 to lose one
draws this move loses King f8 King f6
King e8 and once again white
takes control of the e8 square promotes
his pawn wins the game
Bravo however we haven't won the game
yet young man what do you think young
man what would you say King to f3 well
then I would just step up or maybe I
should step up here so you move
backwards you haven't helped your cause
and man in the red you had you were
gonna make a suggestion okay you're
correct you have to move your king but
where should he move the King young man
with the yes you King to g4 that doesn't
really help your cause because I moved
back now you haven't really made a
progress well I was just putting the
position back so who else has a
suggestion yes King to e4 brilliant move
brilliant move now let's see what I
could do I could move my King back here
to e7 but then you would bring your King
up so I'm going to put your King in
opposition now basically you want me to
move to move first yes now what would
you do
exactly
so basically in this position you want
black to move because then his King has
to get out of the way so you play the
move e 2 e 3 now I'm very unhappy about
it but I'm going to have my have to move
my King and now what do you do what do
you do young man
exactly exactly
King to f5 now I want to stay in front
of the pond so I'm going to go King to
e7 and then again on to e4 and now King
here exactly you've learned to get to
this position not to push up the pond
too fast a brilliant move now again I
have to make way let me make way like
this King to f7 gentleman in the back
yes sir
you in the back you now what do you do
okay if you advanced upon I'm stepping
in front of your king so you have an
opportunity to make a little headway
with your king trip yes
well King hit f5 I'll go back you want
to go deeper into the position yes in
that yes indeed
exactly King to d6 King to e8 and now
young man brilliant very very very well
done so now your King has conquered the
e6 square whenever we're in this
situation white is going to win the game
I have to I only have two legal moves
let me choose one yes brilliant I'll
come back and again exactly now again I
only have two legal moves if I go here
I'm afraid that you will go here and and
waltz your pawn through however what if
I go here young man in the orange right
behind yes I
brilliant and now there's nothing I can
do you will and make a queen and I've
lost okay so what we learn in this
particular position is that sometimes
unlike normally in the opening in the
middle game when we want to move
sometimes it's better to give our
opponent the opportunity to move young
man what would you like to say
yeah exactly
well it's always it's the dream of every
pond to promote that's for sure
and if in this case we have an e pond
I'm sure the e8 square is the dream pond
for the pond now I have one of my
favorite favorite puzzles this is going
to be really easy for you guys very very
easy now in this position right in this
position how many of you know that when
there's only two nights and a king
versus a king that it's a draw this is a
draw this is a drop rava so I'm going to
give this position to you but I'm going
to help you out so you know you know
that I can't win with two knights and a
king against your king so you know I'm
going to play white you're going to play
black so you know it's a draw but I'm
gonna help you out I'm going to give you
a pawn now now if you could get a queen
you're gonna win the game but I'm gonna
even help you so how many of you already
like blacks position I sure do because
you can't lose and there's a chance if
you could get a pawn you might win but
I'm gonna help you out some more okay
I'm gonna give you a knight so you have
a knight and a pawn and I have two
nights uh-huh now how many of you really
like the position for black exactly
you're going to come with okay now to
help you out even more I'm gonna give
you another night so how many of you
think you can win this position with
black now okay so you all agree that you
write like to play black right because
you've got two nights tuna you got an
extra pawn you might promote the pawn
and win the game right why not right but
you're going to move your knight on your
next turn and then your king yeah well
guess what
about this position it's all about
timing can you imagine that if it's
White's turn he wins
isn't that a shock
what could white do yeah you forgot yes
well if you go night e to check but this
night is on h7 where would it go
curr hey well along and by that time
this night will move this king will move
and you're gonna Queen and I'm lost
yay but let's check this out the
question is timing if it's black to move
he wins so the crucial question is whose
turn is it now imagine that I'm white
EEE and I go Knight h7 to g5 now it's
your turn what can you do you can't move
your king right okay so what would you
like to do which one
you've got to this guy this guy the guy
on h2 knight on h2 to g4 okay now what
can I do
how about night on g5 to f3 check mate
the pond is queening deponent you can't
capture - ah
check mate the pond is ready - Queen o
how many of you would like to move the
other night yes should we move the other
Knight to g4 or maybe d1 ok Knight g4
and now what move am I going to make
here you take mate yeah work in your
King move where can the King can't move
anywhere so see I tricked you you didn't
have any move to avoid checkmate
aren't I a dirty coach I'm the worst no
matter which Knight you move if you move
this night I checkmate you here if you
move this night for example to g4 or f1
doesn't matter I check mate you here
isn't that a surprising pattern surprise
so always you have to ask yourselves if
I were going to show you a position you
should ask me whose turn is it whose
turn is it to move ok the next thing I
wasn't too sure a couple of weeks ago a
couple of weeks ago I gave you guys a
problem and you guys want that I wasn't
a hundred percent sure that you did it
really really good so now you're going
to have to do it again and as we'll see
you're gonna have to use timing you're
going to have to use timing so are you
ready your job is to checkmate me but
I'm only going to give you two bishops
to do it easiest peasy
ok I'm gonna choose the
correct correct
okay who would like to start us off and
as we know as we know the only way
you're going to be able to check my king
is you have to put me into the corners
okay that's the only hint I'm gonna give
you okay let's get started what would
you do young
what would your move be with white yes
excellent that's a very good choice
Bishop the c3 checking my king I I'm
gonna have to go let's say sideways in
the back far back young man okay white
Bishop to e4 check let's say I go back
young man what would you do that's an
excellent decision King to f4 now I
can't lose my King here because your
bishop controls the f6 square I'm gonna
move my king here amen now this is a
really excellent move seriously this is
really good because it boxes my king in
notice how your bishops control all the
squares in front of my king that's going
to force me to move side to side
in the back what would you do white
bishop okay Bishop f5 check you'll
permit me to run you want to force me
backwards young lady in the back yes
Bishop on e4 - where - Esther
be careful be careful you don't want to
give me an opportunity to capture one of
your bishops young man in the red
brilliant move Bishop to e5
now notice you've reduced my options
I can't move my King here I can't move
my King here I only have a choice of
moving backwards let's say I move
backwards here now what would you do
young man white Bishop to f6 okay I
could move back it's okay no harm no
foul I don't feel like you made progress
so you'll move back sometimes sometimes
you make a mistake you have to take your
move back young man
wonderful move really really brilliant
because once again you see how those
bishops are coordinating beautifully
I'll move my king here young lady
excellent very very good I think you
guys are getting the hang of things so
you can see I'm getting my options are
being reduced but I'm gonna play King d7
and now young man excellent excellent
once again you see I can't move here
here or here so all the squares I'd like
to move to to get away from the corner
are blocked
I can't move here I can't move here I'm
going to back up ha young man
excellent choice excellent now I'm going
to move up young lady you're not so sure
yes careful careful careful I have an
idea
young man excellent now with this move I
just want to pause and point something
out you'll all heard those you know
double attacks those types of tactics
right but this is a very good move
because it actually is a good defensive
move you defend both your bishops it's
worth noting okay
so what can I do I'm going to drop back
with my king you guys have made great
progress young men excellent decision
excellent decision King to e6
now Wow
what I want to do is avoid one of the
corners I know you guys are driving me
into the corner so I'm going to try to
stay in the center as long as I can how
many of you would like to play Bishop to
e7
darn I was hoping that you'd do that
young lady c6 checking my king and ex
was an excellent move what can I do I
have to go back young man okay I'm
trying okay Bishop to e7 check now I get
to come out thank you oopsy-daisy okay
so what you guys have got to figure out
just give it some thought for a moment
what you guys that's a good move
that's a good move what you guys have
got to figure out is how you're gonna
drive me into this corner right you can
see that I can't move over in fact you
really could predict my next move you
know I'm going to have to move here but
then once I move here you guys have got
to figure out how to stop me from moving
back in then okay King to f7 then I have
no choice I have to go King to c8 young
man in the far back yes
how about here come on Rudy you've got
where are you gonna go it's okay if you
want to go back your king was good on e6
yeah it's a good it was a good decision
okay so now I'm moving back now you guys
know that my next move is going to be
king here you know that young man what
would you do
ah King to defy but has that helped your
cause still have young lady you probably
should move your king back okay so far
you guys have haven't made a big
progress
yes young man brilliant brilliant move
brilliant move
now we're gonna about to understand why
this move is brilliant I'm going to play
King here okay young man okay very good
you brought your king to the d6 square
very very good
I want to avoid the corner so I'm going
to keep my king centralized okay Bishop
to f6 check very very good okay
now King here so far you guys have done
really well you see how you're kind of
squeezing me into the corner now think
about this for a moment what is my next
move
what is black's next move I I'm going I
have no choice right I have to move my
king to b8 where it's getting closer to
the corner so you guys have to figure
out how you're gonna set up your bishops
and your rooks what move would you like
to make okay but then I escape
yay so you want it's correct that you're
going to want to move your bishop but
you're going to want to keep this square
under control
if you move you're very very very good
very very good now now you see that
you're forcing me I can't move my King
here here here or here I have to play
King here yes excellent decision
excellent decision King to c6 now let me
see what I want to do I want to escape
here young man
Bishop to D that's ok Bishop to d4 check
well let me see what if I go here yes
what would you do
yes very very good so now guess what you
just did you gave me the move your
timing in chess is you want me to move
back into the corner I hate doing it but
I have to
okay give this position some thought for
just a moment young lady what do you
think you should do this one or this one
this one where okay Bishop to b4 it's
okay move I'm going to think about it I
want to play I don't want to go into the
corner
check I have to move King now you've got
me where you want me
but it's your king in the best position
King to be five that it would allow me
to escape
yes King to see seven and now this is
the grand accomplishment look at what I
have to do i-i-i don't have this square
your bishop controls i don't have this
this or this square your King controls I
have to move King to a8 young lady are
you gonna give me stalemate
no okay too bad I was hoping what what
what would you like to play
okay very good
where would you move your white bishop
okay so in this position let's reverse
the roles for just a moment let's
reverse the timing of the position now
let's imagine it's not white to move
that let's imagine it's black to move as
black I have no choice I have to move
King here and it's checkmate in two
moves now how do you checkmate in two
moves hi what that yes you did
what's that that's exactly what I'm
talking about giving up the tempo so
we're gonna go back to this position for
a moment and we know that this is going
to be my next move and then you're going
to checkmate me in two moves with Bishop
c5 and Bishop d5 checkmate so what you
want to do is just lose the move you
just want to lose you want to give me
the move
so you've got lots of ways that you
could lose a move you could move your
bishop back you could move this Bishop
back you could move your king you've got
lots and lots of choices which one would
you like to choose what's your choice
this is an excellent choice this is a
winning move another winning move would
you agree that this too is a winning
move it's still checkmate in two right I
move my king check King Bishop mate okay
so timing and Chasse you don't see it
really in the opening and the opening
you want to you always want it to be
your move in the middle game most of the
time you really want to have the move
but oftentimes when we get to the
endgame
it's you get those peculiar situations
where you would like your opponent to
move so I'm going to give you one last
problem and this is a tricky one you
ready you guys are white now who thinks
white can win
who thinks black can win draw sorry
who thinks here's the important one who
thinks it depends on whose turn it is
okay so let's figure this one out
let's imagine that it's black to move
and black moves here gentlemen in red
you sir
and then guess what
the pond goes right in so if it's booked
and his dream comes true so if it's
black to move black loses on the spot
how about king here young man and same
thing right so if it's black to move
black losers let's imagine it's white to
move what would you guys do if you were
white
okay how many think this is a real good
move don't have much support but you're
right King c8 and now young-ran yours
you are ready young lady you're ready
okay what would you do
brilliant excellent a really brilliant
decision what can I do if I move my king
to d8 you're gonna go b7 and it's a
queen I have to go here and now and now
King up C aren't I a mean guy I tricked
you
here are the whole lesson I've been
talking about timing and how it's
important sometimes that you give the
move to your opponent but in this case
white wins regardless sorry about that
I'm just a mean guy so are there any
questions about timing we'll let you get
to play your chess games yes young man
well what questions
sure in the opening and in the middle
game you always like it to be your turn
because you can attack your opponent
capture something gain space mobilize
your pieces so in the opening and the
middle game timing isn't as a big a
factor as the end game young men yes
timing means that sometimes you want it
to be your opponent's move that is to
say like that example we just showed
here let me just show it to you again
because I just think it's such a
beautiful pattern sometimes as we've
seen after Knight g5 poor black whatever
movie he can't move his King
he can't move his pawn and whichever
Knight move he makes
he gets checkmated from one side or
checkmate it on the other side so
something so sometimes let's say it was
white to move here yes yes well then you
just be fine but so if it was white to
move in this position what move would
you make with white
well I would take it either way so if
you had the white pieces what move would
you make you want it to be black smooth
wouldn't you yes in that anywhere right
you could do anywhere you move your King
let's just say King here you would say
okay my friend go ahead and move one of
your Knights and I'll check make you
values thank you all for coming
nice of you and we'll see you next
Sunday